React router is commonly used to create different
routes for pages in react applications. This
course will teach you how to use react
router to create your own routes in react,
we're going to learn about react router, and its
different concepts such as creating different
routes for different pages in react. Also,
we're going to learn how to nest a route of a
page under another page. hooks like US history,
use params, use locations and use route match,
also how to fetch a query string in form of a
variable from the URL. So let's get started.
Okay, so let's start by creating a
new react app. I'm going to type NP x
create react app, and the name of our app,
which I'm going to give react router tutorial.
Now what is going to do, it's going to go to NPM
website or NPM repository and going to take all
of the things needed to create a new react app.
And it's going to put all of those things into
this folder, React router tutorial, it's going
to find all of the dependencies that we need to
create our react app. And it's going to basically
initialize a boilerplate code for our react app.
Alright, so it has successfully
initialized our new react app.
Now we need to switch to that folder,
what we can do is either we can type cd,
and the name of the folder, you can switch
this way. Or what you can do is you can
open that folder in VS code, which in my case is
this folder. And I'm going to select this folder.
So here we go. I folder has been
opened in the VS code successfully.
So what I'm going to do now is I'm going to type
NPM start. So it's going to start our react app.
Here's our react app running successfully. So
what I'm going to do now is I'm going to go I'm
going to go to the src folder. And I'm going
to get rid of those things that we don't need
this, this, this and this, we're going to get rid
of these four files. And we're going to remove the
places that they were being used. So over here.
And we're going to get rid of all of these styles.
Inside app j s, app dot j s, I'm going
to get rid of this. Get rid of logo.
And now you'll see that our app will have nothing
to show. Me refresh it. Yep, there you go.
It's an empty page. Okay, so what
I'll do now is I'm going to type
h1, h1, react, router Dom tutorial, for this
react router tutorial. Let's save this and see.
Yes, it has successfully rendered this over here.
So let's create a different component for header.
When you create a new component
called a new folder called components,
it's not necessary to create a separate folder
for components, but it's a good practice.
I'm going to create a different component for
header dot j, s. And I'm going to type our A,
F, C underscore RFC and press Enter.
And let's copy the same thing. Over
here we go. Let's first center align this thing.
And then we're going to start with our tutorial.
So I'm going to give it a few of the styles in
app dot CSS. I'm going to get rid our display flex
and justify content. No,
sorry. I mean to say align
items to center and flex direction is going to be
column because we want everything to be top down.
You know, aligned. So yeah,
here we go. You're nice.
It is in the center. So yeah, I haven't done
this. imported the header component. Yeah.
header is not defined. Let's
just import it manually.
Here we go. It should work fine now. Yep, here
we go. It's working fine. So now we're going
to install react router DOM. So I'm going
to open a new terminal and type NPM I react
router DOM. And you know what I'm gonna go to
header and get rid of this dev Let's use the
React fragment. So if you don't know what react
fragment is, you can watch my previous video on
eight clean code practices in react, it's going to
help you a lot 2000 years later, or it's finally a
react router Dom has installed successfully.
So I'm going to go to my app JS component.
And to use our react router DOM, what
we'll need to do is we're going to have to
cover this whole react app in something
called browser router, browser router,
which comes from react router DOM,
so you can see it has auto imported.
So I'm going to pull off my app in this.
Alright, here we go. Let's close this terminal.
I think I'm going to have to restart my
application. So let me just do that quickly.
Alright, it's fine now. So what are we what are
we going to do next is we're going to create
different different routes for different
different pages that we're going to work with.
So let's create a route for homepage about page
and profile page. Yeah, so I'm going to type route
and press Enter. And you can see
route has auto imported from VS code
coming from react router, Dom VS code has auto
imported it. So I'm going to give it a path.
This is going to be your homepage. So it's going
to be this. And we have to give it a component,
which we'll create in a second. So let's duplicate
these paths. Another one will be for about.
And the third one will be for profile. So let's
create these pages. First, I'm going to create a
new folder with the name of pages. Home dot j s,
I'm going to create a file called about dot j s.
And the third file will be profile dot j s. Next,
let me quickly write some code inside of this
type homepage. Remove these divs and add h1.
Next, same thing with the about page. bout page.
And the profile page. All right, good.
profile page. Alright, cool. So we have
created all of our three routes. Now let's
test these routes if these are working or not.
So let me save my app real quick. Okay,
there's an ad a worse theater. Okay,
we haven't even the components, obviously.
So let's just give this home. Go
Oh, sorry. My bad, we have to import all of
these components first. So import home from
slash home. And I'm going to do for
about and profile as well. So about
and profile. Let me just bow and put off five.
Here we go. So we have created three routes.
This is how you create a route in react by
using react router DOM. So you can see it's
currently in the root folder, I mean, in
the root path. So it's giving us homepage.
Let's go to the about page route. There we
go it giving us about but you can see the
homepage is also appearing here and
about page is also appearing here.
Why is that happening? Because you can see it, it
has about page as well. And this route as well.
In this init spot, it has route as well.
So what we can do is we can type exact,
so it's gonna go exactly to this path and
not nowhere else. So if it type about it's
going to click open about page. And if you
type profile, it's going to go to work.
Okay, I have made this mistake. Yeah, now
it's gonna work fine. If I go to profile page,
it's gonna open the profile page.
Another thing which you can do apart
from exact is you can use something called
switch. So if I type switch over here,
and we're going to take all of these three
inside of the switch, and I've imported
the switch from react router DOM. So is what
switch does is when you go to a particular path,
let me remove this exact from here. So it's
gonna find whatever it finds first is gonna
stop there. For example, it has written slash
profile. So it has found the slash path First,
it has matched this path slash with this. So
it is found the homepage is going to render
if we use Switch Murphy type exact, then
we're not going to have the same problem now.
You can see it's rendering the
profile. Now, let me type about.
Alright, here we go about page. All right, one
more thing. So we don't need to manually type this
in the URL. So what can we do to go to another
page, in the traditional web development in the
HTML, we use something called a tag to go to a
different page. So we can use that over here as
well. But it has a disadvantage, what disadvantage
is there, when we click on this a tag, it's
going to refresh our page, let me demonstrate
that thing. So I'm going to go to our header,
I'm going to create a navigation menu for our
app. Let me create an unordered list over here.
I'm going to create few list items, and have
a new tag inside of it with h ref of a partner
first is going to be the homepage. So let's
type slash over here and give it a name of home.
Alright, so I'm going to duplicate these
multiple times, and going to give this about
about seem to get a profile,
and profile. Let's save this.
And currently looks a bit ugly. So I'm
going to give it a little bit of styling.
So let's go to our app CSS. And I'm going to
add some styling to it. Let me give this a
class name. First, I'm going to give this class
name of now. Yeah. Let's give it some styles.
So I'm going to type list style type is going to
be none so that it doesn't displace the bullet.
And I'm going to type width to be 500
pixels. So I'm going to type display, flex
and justify content to be spaced
evenly swear it spreads around evenly.
Now you'll see Yep, it has spread around
evenly. Now let's click on one of these links.
If I'm going to click on home, you can
see the page has refreshed over here.
If I click on profile, again, the page has
refreshed we have reached the destination but
the page has refreshed. We don't want the page
to be refreshed. We don't want our components
to be re rendered. So what are we going to do
now. So instead of this a tag, what I'm going
to do is I will use something called link,
which is provided to us by react router DOM.
Let's click on this link. And you can see it
has auto imported. So over here as well. Link.
And lastly, yeah. What do we can't use h ref with
the link, we need to use something called to.
This is the prop that it takes. So let's
save it. Alright, our app has reloaded. And
let's click on About. Now you can see the
page has not refreshed if I click on home,
again. So you see this is the power of react
router DOM, it doesn't refresh your page,
and it takes you to another
page in a blink of an eye.
Alright, cool. So let's discuss some more
features of this library. So let's see if I want a
default route for our app. Now what I mean by that
is let me give a base name over here. If I give
the base name as a tutorial, and save this now you
see if I click on homepage, it's going to take us
to the slash tutorial. If I click on About, it's
going to take a slash tutorial slash about so this
is how you can define a base name for this by
typing base name equals whatever the name that
you need to use. If I click on profile, it's
going to take us slash tutorial slash profile.
So this is a really powerful feature. Let's
check out another feature of the browser router.
I'm going to remove this. And let's say for some
reason, you need to use the refresh feature.
So currently, it's not refreshing our page when
I'm taking it to another route. So if I type force
refresh over here, then you'll see what it does.
If I'm going to go to about you can see the
page is refreshing now it's providing the force
refresh forcely are apt to re render everything.
So you can use force refresh for that,
which I don't think anyone needs to use.
Also, if you want to confirm every time a
user goes to another route, for example,
if I click on About you need to confirm it by some
prompt or by some displaying some modal, what you
can use is called get user confirmation. You can
type get user confirmation, and then inside of
this you can write a class Message to be displayed
whenever the route changes. So I'm going to
write a function inside of it by typing message,
whoops message. And it's going to take a callback
is going to be an arrow function. callback is
going to take window, dot confirm. And you can
pass whatever component that you need to pass
inside of it. Let's say if you create a prompt,
you can pass inside a prompt inside of it or a
modal, but I don't think this is used that much
as well. So this is one of the features that you
can use in react router DOM. So let's remove this.
Yeah. All right, let's move forward.
First of all, I what I want to do is
the let's remove these styles from the
links. I don't want this style. So I'm
going to go to App dot CSS, and let's remove
the styles by typing a removing text decoration.
And go alone will be inherited. Yeah, fine. See,
our pages are not that big. Right now. If you go
to homepage, or if you go to profile page, it's
its height is not that big right now. But let's
say your your page is so big that you need to
scroll down. So whenever you change your route,
what's going to happen, it's going to continue
the other page from the same position. If so
what you want to do in that case, whenever you go
to a different component, you can type like this.
Let me just go over here to homepage. And you
I can, what I can do is I can use use effect.
And instead of use effect, I can type window dot
scroll to zero comma zero. So it's going to do
it's going to continue the other page from the
top and not the previous position that page was
when you were in the other component. So this is
helpful. Okay, so next important thing is if when
we type to some other route that doesn't exist,
right now, let me say anything like something,
and enter, you can see there's nothing being
displayed over here. We want something to display
over here, like 404 error page not found something
like that. So how can we display that over here?
let me create a new page for that. I'm going to
new command create a new page called not found
dot j s. Right? Let's initialize this page, A,
C, press Enter. And I'm going to give it an h1
of four books 404. Not Found. Let's save this.
Now how can we how can we use this? Now we need
to go over here and close this? Yeah, we need
to go over here we need to create another route,
we've created another route. In this case,
we're not going to give it any of the path
such as about our profile or anything,
we're just going to give it a component
not found. And we're going to manually import it.
Here we go. We've imported our not found page.
And here we go. The message is displayed
successfully. If I go to somewhere else,
it's going to still display this message. If I
go to a relevant page, like home about profile,
it's not going to display any of the message.
Alright, so let's move to the next thing, which
is taking parameters from the URL. So let's say
if I want a page like something called post, and
we want some random post. So we want this random
ID to be accessed by us. So what can we do over
here. So currently, it's going to show 404 not
found. So let's create a new page for our post.js.
So what we want to do is want we want to
fetch this particular ID. So let me type ID
is and we're going to display the particular
ID. I'm going to give it h two over here.
Currently, it's not going to
display anything if I go to post.
Okay, we haven't created that out obviously, we
need to go to App j s and create another out.
Here we go. We have created this part
successfully. Now you can see it showing
us ID is equals which we can't do anything if
the slash type anything. It's going to no it's
not a display anything. So what we need to do
now we're going to do is slash ID. So now it's
going to take a random ID from us. So if I go to
post now it's going to display not found because
that page doesn't point needs to have an ID
to display. So let's go back to our pitch.
And now we're going to use our first hook, which
is called use params. Or we can use a match as
well, let me just display, let me just demonstrate
it with the match first. So we're going to go
over here D, D structure the match from here.
And now, what we're gonna do is we're gonna
go over here and type match dot params. And
what what was the name of the params? It was ID,
let's save this. And let's check this out. Now.
Here we go. If I give this let me type random
over here, and press enter. You can see the
ID is generated, and it's displayed over here.
I mean, it's not generated, we have
provided it, but it's displayed over here.
Yeah, so what's the another other way to do this.
The other way to do this is using use params hook,
which is provided to us by react router DOM. So
I'm going to click over here. And you can see
it has auto imported from react router DOM. Now
we don't need this, I'm gonna get rid of this.
I'm gonna use use params. Let's first log this use
params. Let's see, what do we get inside of this.
I'm going to remove this now. So don't get
better. All right, let's log this use params.
and inspect this, you get an object. And this
object has something called ID inside of it,
which is the ID that we have passed over here. Let
me type something and press. Here we go. It has
given us another object with ID of something.
So now, we're going to use this use params.
I'm going to type const, ID equals use params.
And we're going to D structure this ID inside
of the use params. So we have taken out this
ID and we can just use this ID over here. Now.
Let's save this. Let's check here we go
something and we give it a random number.
And here's our ID displayed successfully.
So this is how you can fetch the ID from the
URL. Now let's say we need to use a we don't want
to change our route. But we still need to use
the variables from the URL. For example, if I type
question mark, and I, let's say I type name equals
viewshe. Let's say we want this name this
new How can we fetch this from the URL?
Is there any other way? So we're gonna use
our second hook called use location, use
location, and it's also provided to us by react
router DOM. So we're gonna type use location
over here, let me just log this use location
first. And check what do we get inside of this?
Let's go to inspect. We get an object. So
what does this object has it has a path name.
And it has a search with the value of name
equals viewshe. Let me type something else
first. equals viewshe. And we can type and
last equals Agarwal, which is my name. So yeah,
let's see. Now the value of search has changed
to first equals fusion logic, what? Now how do we
fetch these first and last variables from this
search? You know, variable search object. So
what I'm going to do now, so we're going to
use an inbuilt API from the browser called
URL search params. So I'm going to select it.
And I'm going to type you are l search params.
And I'm going to create an object out of it.
So I'm going to type new URL search params. And
what do we want inside of this use location, we
want this search. So let's type search. Alright,
let's take it in some variable. Let me type
const. query equals new URL search params.
Here we go. So how do we take out the stuff
from this query? So let me just go over here and
h2. And we need to use the first and the
last. So let's first extract the first one.
So query dot get. And in the bracket, we need
to, we need to write the variable that we need to
fetch from the URL. So I'm going to type first
and save this. Let's see what happens. Okay,
here we go. We get the page from here from
the first and let's fetch the last as well.
Last, here we go. So we can type n number of
queries inside of this URL, and we can Then by
using this method, use locations hook. So that's
pretty cool. Now let's see, let's suppose you have
a login feature in your app. And you want user to
access the profile only if that user logs in into
your app. So how are we going to modify our react
router Dom according to that, let's find out.
We're going to go to App j s. And we're going to
create a new state, let's say login. import the
user state from react, here we go. So by default,
login will be false. Login will have false value,
because we are not logged in now admit, let
me just create a button over here to log in.
But nobody has created it.
Let me just take this div and
put it over here so that everything
is centered. Yes, it's centered.
So what I want is, when I tap on this
login, we're going to simulate a login
feature by making this log in as true and it's
going to display log out then. So on click
what it should do, it should set login
as the opposite value. So if it's true,
it's going to be false. If it's false, it's going
to be true. Also, what I'll display over here is
if login is true, if which means
if user has successfully logged in,
then it should display Whoa, what's happening?
Yeah, then it should display logged out.
Otherwise, it should display login.
Let's save this. And let's see if it's working
or not. Okay, it's working fine. So what do we
want to do over here, if our user is not logged
in, he's not going to be able to access the
profile page, and he's going to be redirected
to the home page. So how can we achieve that,
we're going to use something called redirect from
react router DOM. So let's remove this component
from here. how I'm going to do this is here,
we're going to make the child component of this
route. So let's check this over here. If login
is true, if login is true, then it's going to
be able to access the profile page. So profile.
Otherwise, it's gonna be redirected. So redirect.
Where will it be redirected to home page. Here
we go. Alright, let's try clicking on our profile
page. Let me go to about page and let's click on
profile page. You can see we have been redirected
to homepage. We can't access the profile page
now. But the moment we press login, and let's go
to profile page. Now. Now we're able to access
the profile page. So it has became a protected
route for our app. If I'm inside of this profile
page. And if I press logo, let's see what happens.
It's gonna redirect us back to the homepage.
Now there's another way of doing this.
Let me show you, we can use something called
US history, US history hook. So let me just tie
this over here, I'm going to remove all of
this redirect stuff. Make it a normal route now
to working normally now without login. Alright.
So I'm going to, what I'm going to do is I'm going
to send the log in as a parameter inside of this
stuff, send the login as a params. Let's go to
profile and D structure the logging out of here.
Here we go. And let's create a use effect. So use
the effect brands whenever our app is initialized
first time. So I'm going to take the history out
of the US history hook. So let's type US history.
I'm going to assign it to const. History
variable. All right. It has auto imported
from react router DOM, what happened?
Okay, we haven't imported the US effect.
Here we go. Alright, so what do we need to type
inside of the US effect, we need to check if the
user is logged in. Or if the user is not logged
in? What are we going to do if he's not logged in?
Then we will use history. dot push is
going to push this path to our URL.
So it's going to push to the slash page which
is our home page. So let's try this out.
I'm at the homepage, let's go to profile page,
I'm not able to access the profile page. Now,
let's log in. And let's go to profile page. Here
we go. We're successfully in the profile page. And
let's log out now. Whoa, what happened? I think
I have missed some. Yeah. Okay. So if we wanted
to run whenever the login variable changes, so
I'm gonna provide login over here and history,
we're going to provide these two dependencies
inside of the use effect. Whenever these two
dependencies are gonna change. It's going to fire
off this function. Let's try again, we're going to
go to profile, it's not going there. I'm going
to type I'm going to click on login. What am I
saying today? Okay, so let's go to profile now.
Here we go, we're able to access the profile
page. Let's log out. Here we go. We're back at the
homepage, if we want to go to about page about,
let's say, if the user is not logged in, is
going to go to about page, if I click on profile,
see it redirects us to about page. But if you
are logging in, go to profile page. So I hope
you all understood, you know this feature of
react DOM. Let's move to the next feature.
So let's discuss how can we create
nested route inside of a particular page.
For example, if inside of the profile
page, I want to create two routes,
with the name of let's say, view profile, and
edit profile, and I don't want those two routes
to affect our whole react router system, we only
want them to work inside of this profile page. So
let's create two new routes over here. I'm going
to remove this, let me just put it inside of this
round braces and then provide
react fragments to these.
Alright, let's move this. Yeah, so I'm going
to create a navbar inside of a profile page.
I'm going to create a link tag
over here. And let's say view.
And the other link tag, is gonna
have heard it, edit profile, it's
also we haven't created these view profile
Edit Profile components yet. So we also
have to create those view profile.
Here we go. We need to provide it to
it's going to go to work. So first
of all, before doing all of this,
let's create our route and the component first
to read we have these errors out of the way.
So I'm going to go below this. And as
usual, we're going to create a switch.
Whoops, switch. x even has auto
imported or not, yes, it has.
Alright, we need to create two routes. Route
one will have path of slash, view profile.
And it has it's gonna have some component which
I'm going to create next. And the other one will
be the Edit Profile. Edit Profile. Yeah.
Let's create those two components first.
Review, proof filed or GS made a spelling mistake.
reprofiled rj What the heck. br o f i l e. Yes.
Edit profile.whoops.js. Let's create this RFC. And
I'm gonna give it a h two and view profile page.
This component created and
remediated profile image,
Edit Profile page, giving this h2 as well. Yeah,
fine. Let's move on to the next thing. Now we're
going to go back to our profile page. And over
here, we're going to go and give it a to to slash
Edit Profile. And this one to the view profile.
Let's see if it works or not. route is not defined
obviously route and links are not defined yet.
So I'm going to auto import it from the VS code.
With the help of VS code here, here we go.
All of these are important now. Alright,
let's see. What's the error
over here. Link is not defined.
Link is defined. You can see link is defined
over here. Let's meet Let me refresh this. Yep,
it's working fine. Let's go to the profile.
Okay, we have to log in first and let's go to
profile. Okay, we have view profile and edit
profile over here. But it's not working now.
But why is it not working now? Because we
have already created our routes over here.
So what do we need to do? So what do we need to
use now? Because we're going to use something
called use route, match hook, use route
match. So this is the hook that we're gonna
use to help us, you know, move the components
inside of other component. So let me type const.
And I'm going to take out something called
path and something called URL from inside of
this thing. So let's see how can we use this path
and URL, first of all, we want to go to, we don't
want to go to View profile, because it's taking
us to slash edit profile or slash view profile,
we want to go for example, if your add the
profile, we want to take the current URL,
and then append the view profile after it. So
what I'm going to type over here, first of all,
I'm going to remove this standard string
tags, and I'm going to use backticks. Oops.
Like that. Okay, so now we need to
provide a variable inside of it.
Which will be URL. Yep, now it's gonna
work fine. And the same over here.
URL, and I'm going to remove the
string and give it a backtick.
Just like that. So this is how it's going to work.
And what here as well. Okay, we haven't given
the component, prop. So it's gonna be view,
view, bureau file. So it's not auto importing.
Let me just import it over here. Your profile from
have to go one step back and inside of
the components and view profile, same
with the Edit Profile as well as your profile,
I should work now. Then we would have component
component of edit, profile. Yep. So here we go.
We have created our two routes over here. So
what do we need to do now, we need to provide
it the PATH variable. But it's going to know
that the current URL that we are in the current
path that we are in, we only need to append
this particular you, you know, URL to that URL, I
mean path to that URL, or the route to that URL.
So I'm going to type path over here, similarly,
but over here, just like that, you know, the
drill. I'm going to do this created a back tick.
Over here as well. Now, everything should
work fine. Let's try it out. If I click on
View profile, it's going to take us to view
profile page, you can see slash profile slash
view profile. And if I click on Edit Profile,
it's going to take us to edit profile page.
And all of the other routes are working absolutely
fine. There we go. If I click on logout, it's
going to take us to the home page. So thank you
all for watching this react router Dom tutorial.
I hope you all understood what are the concept
that I explained to you in this video. If you
have any confusion, you can comment down below
to ask me I'll reply to you as soon as possible.